AI never sleeps and this week has been
absolutely
insane. We finally have a voice cloner
that can do singing. This AI can
automatically dub videos into different
languages. Plus, it also applies lip
syncs, so it looks like they're actually
speaking the new language. Alibaba drops
a state-of-the-art image generator and
editor. Open AAI releases a real-time
coding agent, which is incredibly fast.
We have some new state-of-the-art
texttospech models. Google low-key drops
a new model that crushes everything. We
have a new open claw alternative that's
even better. It requires 99% less memory
than openclaw and it's 400 times faster.
Nvidia drops a really cool sequential
image model. We also have some
ridiculous humanoid robot demos and a
lot more. So, let's jump right in. First
up, this AI is really cool. It's called
Soul X Singer. And this can generate
singing voices just from a few seconds
of someone's voice. So this is quite
flexible. You can input a reference
voice plus some reference singing audio
and it would basically make them sing
out the song. Here's an example. So
they've actually released this hugging
face link already. We can upload this
reference voice. Let me just play this
for you first. Once upon a midnight
dreary, while I pondered, weak and
weary, over many a quaint and curious
volume of forgotten lore. All right, so
a pretty deep male voice, and then let's
get him to sing out this song. So, let
me play you the reference audio first.
>> Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to
you.
>> All right, so that's just a regular
birthday song. After plugging it through
Soul X singer, here's what we get.
>> Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to
you. Happy birthday to you. All right,
so it basically makes our reference
voice sing out the reference song.
Really cool. Or here's another example.
Let's input Obama's voice. Here's what
it sounds like.
>> Good afternoon, everybody. And on behalf
of the American people, I want to
welcome President Pval, uh, the first
lady and their delegation to the United
States.
>> All right, so that's Obama's voice.
Let's get him to sing out this song.
Hopefully, this does not get copyrighted
by YouTube when I upload it. But if it
does, this section might be muted.
Everybody loves my baby, but my baby
don't love but me.
Nobody but me.
>> All right. And then here's our result.
>> Everybody loves my baby, but my baby
does love nobody but me.
Nobody but me.
>> All right. So that's how you can use
Soul X singer to get anyone's voice to
sing anything. Now this is super
flexible. It has a ton of other
features. So for example, if this is
your original lyrics, you can basically
sing this out first so it knows the
melody of the song. Let's listen to this
original clip first.
>> All right. And then afterwards, you can
input another prompt with another
person's voice. for example.
>> All right. So afterwards, you can
basically get this male voice to sing
this out. And here's what we get.
>> Next, here's a metal example. So, let me
play the reference audio first. I am. I
am. What's wrong
with this society?
>> All right. So, that's a metal example.
Let's hear how this voice sings out the
original song.
>> Very nice. And finally, we also have
this rap example. So, let's hear the
reference first. Serving cat foot in a
glass on a coaster, tipping Michael
Jackson with a Barbie. Now, this is the
story of how I ra the party.
>> Here is the rapper's voice singing out
this song.
>> Come on. Who says who says you're not
perfect? Who says you're not worth it?
>> You can just plug in any voice and then
also hum your own melody and then get
that voice to sing that song out. For
example, here first we enter some lyrics
and then you can hum out the melody
first. So, here's what the melody sounds
like.
All right. And then here's a reference
audio of some voice singing a song. It
can be just any random song.
And then afterwards, we can get this
voice to sing these lyrics with this
melody. Here's what it sounds like.
So, if you want to do like cover songs
or if you want to get a voice to sing
out a song that you composed, this is a
really powerful tool for you to use. The
awesome thing is they've released
everything already. So, if you click on
this GitHub repo, it contains all the
instructions on how to download and run
this locally on your computer. And, you
know, this is actually really small. So,
it's under 3 GB in size, meaning you can
run this on low-end GPUs or even just a
CPU. Anyways, all the links are up here.
So, if you're interested in reading
further, I'll link to this main page in
the description below. Next up, this AI
is also super useful. It's called Just
Dub It. And just like the name implies,
this can take a video and dub it into
another language while also applying lip
sync to the video so it looks like
they're actually speaking out the new
language. Here's an example. So, first
of all, here is the original video in
English.
I took a shower, washing every body part
with actual soap, including all my major
crevices.
>> So, that's English. Next, let's
translate this into French.
>> As you can see, not only is it able to
dub this voice into French, but it's
also able to apply lip sync, so it looks
like he's actually speaking French. Or
here's a Portuguese example.
And then here's a German example.
>> Or here are some other examples for your
reference. Last but not least, my
favorite.
Well, we've been official partners for
one week. Happy anniversary.
Now, the awesome thing is they've
released this already. So, the GitHub
link is actually over here on the bottom
right. And if you click into it and you
scroll down a bit here, it contains the
instructions on not only how to use it,
but also how to train it yourself. So,
if we click on this, here are all the
instructions on how to download and run
this locally on your computer. Notice
that this uses LTX2, which is the best
open-source video generator with audio
natively built in. The nice thing about
LTX2 is it's quite lightweight and it
generates videos really fast. So, you
can run this on most consumer GPUs or
even just a CPU if you have enough RAM.
Anyways, if you're interested in reading
further or checking out more demos, I'll
link to this main page in the
description below. Also this week, the
Quen team continues to release some
awesome stuff. So, they just dropped
Quen Image 2. This is their latest and
most performant image model to date. As
you can see from these benchmarks, Quen
Image 2 far outperforms the last version
of Quen Image as well as Zimage Turbo,
which is all the way down here. Same
with this image editing leaderboard.
It's ranked second place, almost as good
as Nano Banana Pro. Now, Quinn image 2
is especially good at understanding and
following my prompt and generating text
and a ton of different elements all in
one image. So, this image is actually a
generation of Quinn image 2. As you can
see, it's able to get all the text
correct plus all the images that were
specified in the prompt, plus generate
this nice looking diagram. Or here's
another crazier example where you can
specify a ton of stuff in your prompt,
including the exact text and data to
include, but it's able to generate
everything very well. The prompt
basically specifies that this slide
should consist of three columns. The
first column should be this. The middle
column should contain a flowchart with
these exact nodes. And then the last
column should contain this 2x3 table
with these metrics. And as you can see,
it's able to generate everything very
accurately. Or here's another really
complex example with a ton of text and
images and elements. This is like a
itinerary poster, but as you can see,
it's able to generate this very well.
All right, so here's an English example
which contains some specs about Quinn
image 2. So here, first of all, again,
this is super complex. This has a ton of
text, which is all correct. Plus, they
even added a teaser for Quen 3.5 down
here. Plus, it contains the Great Wall
of China in the background. There's just
so many elements jam-packed into this
one prompt, but it's able to generate
everything very well. So, here are the
specs of Quen Image 2. It's great for
outputting complex topography. As I
showed you, this can output 2K
resolution images with microscopic
detail on skin pores, fabric weave,
architectural textures, etc. This is a
unified omni model. So, not only can it
generate images, but it can also edit
images in the same model, just like Nano
Banana. And this is actually really
tiny. This is only 7 billion parameters.
So, this can generate 2K images in
seconds. You can also get this to
generate movie posters. So, here's an
example of that. Or here's an example of
a calendar. And you can even get it to
consistently generate comic pages with
multiple panels like this. And of
course, this can also do photorealistic
images. So, here we have a horse riding
a man. It's great that the Quen team
knows exactly the type of riding that we
want. Here's another example of a super
realistic image. I mean, it's really
hard to tell that this was AI generated.
It's also great at handling different
expressions and poses like this. Now,
they haven't open sourced this yet, but
you can try this out right now on Quen
Chat. So, simply click on this create
image feature here, and here's where you
can select the aspect ratio and enter
your prompt. Anyways, if you're
interested in reading further, I'll link
to this main page in the description
below. Also, this week we have a new top
open-source model called GLM5. This is
incredibly good at reasoning, coding,
and agentic performance. For some of
these benchmarks, it even beats the top
closed models out there like Claude,
Gemini, and GPT. In particular, it's
really good at humanity's last exam,
which tests an AI model's ability to
answer questions from some really
obscure scientific domains, and also
Browse Comp, which test how good an AI
is at browsing the web. Now, I already
did a full review video on GLM5, so I'm
not going to repeat too much here, but
in addition to GLM5, we have yet another
top model called Miniax M2.5. So, here
are some of their performance
benchmarks. The latest M2.5 is the red
bar on the far left. And as you can see
for these benchmarks, it's pretty much
on par with the leading models out
there, including Opus 4.6, Gemini 3 Pro,
and GPT 5.2. It's especially impressive
in terms of SWEBench verified, and
multi-webench, which tests how good an
AI is at agentic coding. Here they say
that M2.5 is state-of-the-art in coding,
agentic tool use and search, office
work, and a range of other economically
viable tasks. And this is insanely cheap
here. They say M2.5 is the first
Frontier model where users don't need to
worry about cost. It costs just $1 to
run the model continuously for an hour
at a rate of 100 tokens per second. So
this is like way cheaper and more
efficient than Opus 4.6. And if you're
working with coding languages other than
Python, M2.5 is even better than Opus in
some cases. So it was trained on over 10
languages across more than 200,000 real
world environments. Here's the rate of
progress comparing Miniax with the top
closed models out there. You can see
that last week, Enthropic releases Opus
4.6, which ranks all the way over here
for this SWEBench verified benchmark.
But just a week after that, Miniax 2.5
basically released a model which is as
good as Opus 4.6. That is some pretty
insane progress. This is extremely good
in professional or office work. This
supports various file types like Word,
PowerPoint, and Excel. For example, I
can just upload a zip file of Starbucks
financial data and then ask it to create
a comprehensive financial analysis of
this in Excel. And then here I can
specify the exact information I want.
And afterwards, here's what I get.
Here's a core financial summary. Here's
the revenue by segment, comp, sales,
profitability metrics, etc., etc. So, it
was able to create this entire
spreadsheet with multiple tabs and
charts in just one prompt from me just
uploading some data. Or here's another
example. I can just input a zip file of
a 100 different invoices in PDF format
and then get it to organize everything
in an Excel spreadsheet. And here's what
I got from that. Now, it's like insanely
easy for you to just work with and
manipulate data with this agent. Or this
can also create PowerPoint presentations
for you natively. So, let's get it to
create a 15 slide presentation on
leading coffee chain brand financial
report etc etc. And here is the
presentation. You can see everything is
very nicely formatted and designed. The
branding is also consistent across this
entire presentation. This is just so
easy. Like before, I would have to spend
at least hours to create a PowerPoint
presentation. But with this agent, I can
do this in like seconds. Or here's
another example of how you can get it to
edit or create documents. So, I need to
plan next year's campus recruitment for
my startup. Help me list the top 20
universities strongest in CS and AAI in
the states. Then research each one's
careerfare situation. After the research
is done, compile it into a word document
for me. And here is my document. You can
see indeed it has given me an overview
of the top 20 CS or AI universities plus
the careerfare details of each one. So
this is great for data scraping, lead
scraping, etc. It's also great at
front-end design. So here, let's get it
to design and code a fully responsive
landing page for a luxury highfidelity
headphone brand. And here is the page.
Look how beautiful and responsive this
is. With this agent ability, it's not
just a regular chat, but it can
autonomously carry out multi-step
workflows for you. So instead of just
outputting a barebones website, it
actually plans everything out, including
the copy, the images, the design, etc.,
and then autonomously does the entire
thing for you. Anyways, this is an
incredibly powerful tool that is among
the top models out there. Best of all,
you can try for free right now using
this Miniax agent interface or you can
also subscribe to their coding plan and
then link this to Claude Code or
OpenClaw. All the links are up here. So,
if you're interested in reading further,
I'll link to this main page in the
description below. Also, this week, the
beast Google continues to release some
insane stuff. So this week they've
released Gemini 3 deep think. Think of
this as like a fine tune of Gemini, but
it's trained to do especially well in
advanced science and research. Here's
how ridiculous this is. Gemini 3 Deep
Think crushes all the top models across
all these benchmarks for ARC AGI 2. This
is incredibly impressive, and I don't
think this bar chart does it justice. So
I'm going to show you this other graph
of all the AI models out there on this
ARC AGI 2 leaderboard. And as you can
see, Gemini 3 deep think is all the way
over here, far outperforming all the
other models. Now, what exactly is this
ARHI2 benchmark? Well, on the surface,
this tests an AI model's ability to
solve visual puzzles. For example, here
is a sample question. It's given a
question and answer pair like this. And
then it's given a new question, and it
needs to apply the same logic. Now, for
a human, this is pretty easy to solve.
You basically need to color these gray
blobs based on how many holes it has.
Now, this is actually very hard for an
AI model because this is applying a new
pattern that it has never learned
before. And that's why you can see that
most of these models perform pretty
badly. That's because technically
speaking, after an AI finishes training,
its weights and parameters are fixed. It
can't learn new information. So, if you
try to feed it a new pattern like this,
it's really hard for an AI to actually
absorb and learn this new information
and apply it. But as you can see for
Gemini 3 deep think, it actually has
this emergent ability. It's a lot better
at actually learning new things and
that's what makes it super powerful. Now
in addition to this ArcGI 2 benchmark,
we also have humanity's last exam where
again it performs incredibly well. If
you're not familiar with humanity's last
exam, this test and AI models knowledge
on some really obscure stuff. So for
example, here are some questions from
this benchmark. The AI needs to provide
a translation for this Roman
inscription. Plus, it also needs to know
how many paired tendons are supported by
a specific bone in hummingbirds. These
are not questions that most people know
the answer to, but as you can see,
Gemini 3 deep think far outperforms the
other models. And then for multimodal
understanding and reasoning, this is not
as impressive, but for code forces, this
is like competitive coding. Gemini 3
deep think leads by a huge margin.
Specifically, it got a staggering ELO
score of 3,455
on code forces. And if you look at this
distribution of human scores, Gemini 3
Deepthink is all the way over here. So,
it's as good as the top 10 humans in the
world. This is really impressive. It
also achieved a gold medal on the
International Math Olympiad in 2025. But
again, we already have models that
achieved gold medal status before, so
this is kind of a saturated benchmark
already. But keep in mind that these are
some of the hardest math questions in
the world. Now, before you get too
excited, this is not available to
everyone. It's only available to Google
AI Ultra subscribers, which is like over
200 bucks a month, plus the Gemini API
via our early access program. But if you
are like working in science or
engineering or whatever, you can also
click on this link to apply to their
early access program. Anyways, if you
are interested in reading further, I'll
link to this main announcement page in
the description below. Next up, this AI
is also super useful. It's called Free
Fuse. And before I explain this, you
kind of need to know what a Lura is. So,
a Lura is basically a fine-tune that can
generate a specific character or art
style or effect or camera angle or
whatever. For example, this Laura can
generate a flat color style like this.
Or this one can generate amateur
photography style. This one can generate
manga style. And this one can generate
faceless gods. Now, here's the problem.
If you add multiple luras into your
generation, for example, if we add like
these three loras, traditionally these
loras would fight or conflict with each
other, this would cause a ton of errors
or glitches or distortion like this. And
that's because when you use multiple
luras, one character's face might bleed
into another. Some styles might
overwrite other styles. The model gets
confused about what belongs where. And
previously, there isn't really a nice
solution to this. But for freefuse, this
is a training free framework that solves
this problem. And so with Freefuse, even
if you input a ton of lures, like
different characters at the top here,
plus different props on this left
column, you can add like many of these
at once into your image, and you won't
get any of these distortions or messed
up faces or any other error. All of
these luras don't conflict with each
other, and the characters look exactly
like intended. Or here's another example
on SDXL. You can see even if you mix
multiple characters in the same
generations, the details are great. We
no longer get any of those distortions
or errors anymore. All these characters
look great and very consistent. Here's a
before and after example. So, if you
don't add Freefuse, then you can see it
mixes up their faces. This looks
absolutely horrible. But with Freefuse,
it retains the look of Harry Potter plus
this other girl. And then here's an
example of Z image. Again, without
Freefuse, then the character's faces
look really messed up. But with
Freefuse, it's able to preserve the
consistency a lot better. If you're
interested in the technical details,
FreeFuse uses a technique called
adaptive token level routing, which
basically dynamically matches the
objects to their corresponding regions
in the image. And this makes sure that
the loras don't overlap or conflict with
each other. The awesome thing is this
has been released already. So, this
already supports Comfy UI and it also
supports Zimage Turbo in Comfy UI.
They're also planning to release Flux 2
client support in the future. All the
installation instructions are on this
page. If you're interested in reading
further, I'll link to this main page in
the description below. Now, in addition
to GLM and Miniax, we have yet another
open-source model which is even crazier.
It's called Nan Beige 4.13B
and this is an absolute beast for its
size. This one is super tiny. It's only
three billion parameters. So, you can
actually run this on most consumer grade
devices. But here's the crazy thing.
Here are its performance benchmarks
against Quen 3 models which are like 10
times larger. But as you can see, it's
even more performant. It's particularly
good in terms of like deep search,
coding, math, tool use, graduate level
science questions, and also this one is
particularly impressive. So, this is
again humanity's last exam, which test
an AI on these really obscure scientific
questions. But as you can see, even
without tool use, in other words,
without web search or using any tools to
look for data, this scores 12.6 on this
benchmark, which is actually incredibly
impressive for just a tiny 3 billion
model. This means it has an incredible
amount of world knowledge jam-packed
into this one model. Not only that, but
it's also great at agentic task. So,
this can do more than 500 rounds of tool
invocations. In other words, you can get
this to like work autonomously by itself
for over 500 rounds to solve a
particular task. Again, really
impressive for just a 3 billion
parameter model. Now, the awesome thing
is this has been released already. And
if you click on files and versions, this
is quite tiny. This is less than 8
gigabytes in size, so you can fit this
comfortably in most GPUs or Macs. And
then here it contains all the
instructions on how to download and run
this locally on your computer. Anyways,
if you are interested in reading
further, I'll link to this main page in
the description below. If you want to
generate AI music, one of the best
platforms to use is definitely MCA, the
sponsor of this video. Let's listen to
an example. Can you tell if this is real
or made with AI?
I'm the spark in the dark.
>> Watch it blown. HEY, HANDS UP.
>> WE RUN THE ROOM.
>> HANDS UP. WE RUN THE ROOM.
>> Stepping camera loves me. I don't need
permission.
>> I turn into my
head.
Now, Mora V8 is extremely good at
generating vocals. It sounds extremely
dynamic, expressive, and very realistic.
Here's an example.
>> Walking slow, cameas
on my lips gasoline. Every step make the
marble shake. Whispers follow but we
don't break. Silk and steel in a single
breath. Smile sharp like a sudden
thread.
>> Instead of looping the same stuff over
and over, MCA V8 uses its music chain of
thought engine to think like a human
songwriter, building intros, verses,
choruses, and climaxes that feel alive
and deliberate. In fact, here are some
performance benchmarks for your
reference. Note that it's even better
than Sunno V5. Plus, they have an AI
audio editor which gives you
professional mixing and mastering tools.
You can microedit sections of your song.
And my favorite part, you can even
export individual stems for your own
post-production. And if you're having
writer block, they have a massive
collection of genre templates like EDM,
R&B, Latin, and blues to kickstart your
creative process. This is one of the
best music platforms out there. So
definitely give MCA V8 a try. The link
will be in the description below. In
humanoid robot news, we have a ton of
really cool demos this week. First of
all, we have this new demo from Westlake
Robotics of their humanoid robot called
Titan01. This is quite a new robot that
hasn't really been featured before, but
here they're showing a demo of how you
can teleoperate this robot remotely from
anywhere. So, for example, the dude
can't go home and be with his family for
Chinese New Year. So, instead, he just
puts on this VR headset plus these
gloves, and he can teleoperate this
robot in real time and interact with his
daughter. It's kind of a sad video, like
this dude needs to keep working during
Chinese New Year. But, as you can see,
the teleaoperation technology of this
robot is very good. You can operate this
remotely to walk around and pick stuff
up and carry stuff. It's quite flexible
and I think this technology would be
especially useful for like dangerous
work such as construction or mining etc
where you might not want to risk a human
life. So what you would do instead is
just train humans to teleoperate these
robots in these dangerous environments.
Now in addition to that Titan01 humanoid
robot, we have another demo. This time
it's from Robot Era's L7 humanoid robot.
This is again not a very popular robot.
It hasn't gotten as much attention as
like Uni Tree or Optimus, but as you can
see, this is very, very flexible. Here,
they're showing a demo of it doing a
full-on sword dance. The robot can
maintain balance while pulling off these
really aggressive spins and high-speed
martial arts moves all autonomously.
This is a great stress test for its
whole body coordination, and it pulls it
off very well. So, you know, Uni Tree
isn't the only robot company that can
now do spin kicks and kung fu. A ton of
other Chinese robotic companies are also
catching up. Now, in addition to that
robot era L7, we also have a new demo
from this new AGI bot. This is their
upcoming humanoid robot. And here you
can see it's incredibly capable at doing
these extreme kung fu moves, including
high kicks, deep lunges, spinning
maneuvers. I mean, it's just super
flexible. And the robot isn't just
mimicking poses. It's actually executing
very explosive high torque movements
that require very precise and
simultaneous balance and power. You can
think of this as like a stress test for
the robot's actuators or basically its
motors. To throw a kick without falling,
the robot must calculate its center of
mass in real time. And this is very hard
to execute. We still haven't been able
to see the figure or optimist do spin
kicks like this. Now, besides those very
impressive, flashy kung fu videos,
here's a more humble demonstration from
Unitere Robotics. So, here they've
gotten the G1 robot to actually do stuff
in a factory. You can see it's doing
these really intricate tasks such as
picking up small components and
assembling them together. Unlike the
previous showy videos, this one is all
about dexterity. The robot needs to use
fine motor control in their hands to
manipulate these small objects. This is
also really tricky because the robot
needs to understand the orientation and
apply exactly the right amount of
pressure to snap things into place
without breaking it. So, this is a very
impressive demonstration of its
precision and dexterity. Now, instead of
just kung fu, here's another demo by yet
another robot called the Tien Gong 3.0,
and it's able to pull off a really
impressive break dancing move like this.
I haven't even seen the Uni G1 be able
to do this. The agility and balance of
this is just insane. Also this week,
Bite Dance unleashes by far the best AI
video generator out there, Seed Dance
2.0. This can do some insane stuff like
generating coherent fight scenes like
this. And this is so good at following
my prompt. Like I can specify a sequence
of different actions in my prompts,
including different camera movements,
different dialogues, different
expressions, etc. And it's able to
handle this so well. like I don't even
need to prompt it twice. It just got
everything perfectly in one shot. Now, I
already did a full review video on Cance
2.0, so I'm not going to repeat too much
here. See this video if you haven't
already to be mind-b blown. But in
addition to Cance 2.0, actually, Bite
Dance also teased another super cool
video generator called Alive. And this
can also generate videos with audio. So,
here's how it works. This is a unified
audio and video generator. So for its
inputs, this can take in text or
reference images or reference audio to
use all within a single framework. Here
are some examples.
>> Hey Lumi, set evening mode.
>> Evening mode activated. Enjoy your
evening.
>> You guys remember last road trip?
>> Of course.
>> The lake was awesome.
That was a killer workout.
>> I am totally exhausted.
>> Good job today, team.
>> Look at this part. It's fascinating.
>> Oh, yeah. That is really great.
>> All right, so those were some texttov
video examples. You can see the
characters are very expressive and the
lip-s sync is really good. Now in
addition to text to video, you can also
upload some reference images of
characters or objects which you want to
insert into your video. So here are some
examples.
>> The weight of centuries
held within these forgotten words truly
astonishing.
>> Why you called? And no, I haven't
changed my mind about the deal. It's too
risky for us right now.
>> Now, here's the win rate between this
new Alive model versus other video
models with audio such as LTX2, Sora,
and also VO3.1. As you can see, for
motion quality, visual aesthetic, visual
prompt following, plus audio quality, on
average, Alive wins more often than the
other models. Now, at the top of the
page, they have released a GitHub repo,
but currently there's no code or
anything yet. I'm quite early to this,
but hopefully they will open source
this. Plus, here it says they have an
online demo coming soon. Anyways, if
you're interested in reading further or
checking out more demos, I'll link to
this main page in the description below.
All right, next up, we have a new really
cool AI called Pico Claw. Now, you might
have heard of OpenClaw or Claudebot. And
this is basically an open- source
framework that lets you run an AI 24/7
on a server or on your computer, and you
can talk to it via Telegram or WhatsApp
and get it to do things. If you're not
familiar with OpenClaw, I already did a
full tutorial a few weeks ago when it
first came out, so see this video to
learn more. Now, OpenClaw was quite
bulky. It was a pain to install. But
this week, we have a serious contender.
So, this guy developed Pico Claw, which
is an ultraefficient version of
OpenClaw. And get this, this can even
run on really cheap hardware. Plus, it
only requires 10 megabytes of memory to
run. And it only takes a second to boot
up. That's pretty crazy. Here it says
this is 99% less memory than OpenClaw
and 98% cheaper than a Mac Mini. This is
also lightning fast. It has a 400 times
faster startup time and it boots in just
1 second. And this basically works the
same as OpenClaw. You can also link your
AI to WhatsApp or Telegram and then get
it to do stuff. Now, on this page, it
contains all the instructions on how to
download and run Pico Claw on your
device or server. And here it contains
instructions on how to link this to
Telegram or other chat apps. Anyways,
this thing is blowing up. It has already
gotten like almost 6,000 stars within a
few days. If you're interested in a much
cheaper and efficient alternative to
OpenClaw, then definitely check this
out. I'll link to this main page in the
description below. Also, this week,
OpenAI releases an ultraast realtime
coding agent called GPT 5.3 Codeex
Spark. So, this is essentially a coding
agent, but optimized for speed. Here's a
comparison with the regular Codeex
versus this new Codeex Spark. And as you
can see, if you get both of them to
build a snake game, you can see that
Codex Spark executes this way faster.
It's pretty much done in just a few
seconds. Whereas for the regular Codeex,
it's still thinking after all this time.
Or here's another example. Here we're
getting it to create a plan for a
landing page. And as you can see, Codex
Spark can execute this in like 2
seconds. Here's another example where we
get it to translate a file into multiple
languages. And again, Codex Spark is
just way faster. Now, of course, with
speed, you do need to sacrifice some
quality, so it's not as accurate or
performant as the regular 5.3 codecs,
but it's way faster. This is designed to
feel like real time, generating over
a,000 tokens per second. Now, here they
say Codex Spark has a context window of
128K tokens and currently it's text
only, so you can't upload reference
images or anything like that. Next, if
you're wondering how to use it, they're
currently rolling this out as a research
preview for ChatGpt Pro users in the
latest Codeex app CLI as well as the VS
Code extension. Anyways, if you're
interested in reading further, I'll link
to this main announcement page in the
description below. Also, this week we
have a new state-of-the-art image
generator and editor. It's called
DeepGen 1.0, and it even beats some of
the top models out there. First of all,
here are some examples of its text to
image capabilities. You can see it's
pretty good. It can generate different
types of art styles plus text. And then
here are some examples of its text
rendering capabilities. Again, it's
pretty good. And then here are some
other examples for your reference. Now,
in addition to just generating images,
this can also edit images. You can add
stuff to an image, you can change the
text of an existing image, or you can
replace objects or turn an image into
anime style. Or here's another cool
example where you can get it to solve a
maze like this. Or you can get it to
generate a different view of the scene
or get it to predict what would happen
afterwards. Now, here are some
performance benchmarks for your
reference. So, apparently in terms of
textto image generation, DeepGen is on
par with the top open- source models out
there, including Zimage Turbo as well as
Quen Image Edit. And if you look at this
chart here, which compares the
performance of Deep Gen's image editing
abilities as well as image generation
abilities, apparently it even beats Nano
Banana. I think this is just the first
version as well as Quinn image and
Cream. The awesome thing is they've
released this already. So if you click
on this GitHub repo and you scroll down
a bit here, it contains all the
instructions on how to use it. However,
notice that if I click on this deep gen
folder on hugging face, the total size
of everything is 72 GB. though it's not
going to be able to fit within most
consumer devices. Anyways, if you are
interested in reading further, I'll link
to this main page in the description
below. Also, this week we have a new
state-of-the-art texttospech generator.
It's called MOSS, and this is really
good. So, first of all, here's a demo.
>> Hello,
look how long we've been chatting. I
still haven't said who I am.
Okay, I'm Simo and what you just heard
wasn't a human voice. It was me powered
by the Moss text to speech family, a
real production level speech model. Now,
like most texttospech generators, you
can also input just a few seconds of
someone's voice, and it's really good at
cloning their voice. So, for example,
here's a clone of David Atenboroough.
>> The cubs are just 12 weeks old when
winter arrives.
The season is long and the weather is
only going to get worse.
Temperatures will soon plummet to 40°
below zero.
For these fragile lives, the cold is a
relentless enemy that never sleeps.
Their mother is their only shield.
>> And then here's a clone of Elon Musk.
>> You know, why why why are we here? Um
what's the origin of the universe? where
what is the end? Um
what are the questions that we don't
even know to ask?
>> Maybe maybe we're here because the
universe uh wanted to know itself and
then then maybe it ends when it you know
forgets.
>> All right, so here's a comparison
between all the top closed and open-
source texttospech generators out there.
Now for this first column, the lower the
score, the better. This is basically the
error rate. And as you can see, Moss TTS
is quite low among the models. And then
for similarity score, this is like how
good it is at cloning someone's voice.
You can see it's incredibly good. It
even beats Quen 3TS. Plus, note that it
supports all these different languages.
The awesome thing is they've released
this already. So, if you click on this
GitHub repo here, it contains all the
instructions on how to download and run
this on your computer. And note that
they've released a ton of different
models. Now, the main one is just Moss
TTS. This is great for voice cloning.
So, you can upload a few seconds of
someone's voice and it would clone that
voice. And you can get them to say
anything you want with a transcript. And
then we also have this MOSS TTSD model.
And this is good for expressive multie
and ultralong dialogues. So, for
example, if you want to generate a
podcast with two hosts or if you want to
generate an audio book, this is the best
one to use. And then we also have this
voice generator where you can design
your own synthetic voice from scratch.
They also have this realtime model which
as the name implies you can use this TTS
in real time. It has ultra low latency.
And then we also have this model which
is great for creating sound effects. The
awesome thing is all these models are
released already. Plus the size is
actually quite small. So if you look at
this main 8 billion parameter model,
this is around 17 GB in size. And then
the smaller 1.7 billion parameter model
is only 6 GB in size. So you can fit
this comfortably with most GPUs.
Anyways, all the links are up here. So
if you're interested in reading further,
I'll link to this main page in the
description below. In addition, we also
have another TTS called MOTTS. And this
is incredibly lightweight and fast. And
this is optimized to generate
highquality speech in English and
Japanese only. So, it doesn't support as
many languages as the previous TTS, but
this is also really good. Here are some
examples. So, first of all, we can
upload a reference voice first. It just
needs a few seconds. So, here is the
reference voice.
>> Hello, my name is John. I'm living in
Japan now. Nice to meet you. What's your
name?
>> All right. And then let's get John to
read this transcript out. Here's what it
sounds like.
>> The old library was silent, save for the
gentle ticking of a clock somewhere in
the shadows. as I ran my fingers along
the dusty spines of the books.
>> Not bad. And then here's another English
example. First of all, here is the
reference voice.
>> Hello, my name is Anna. I'm living in
Japan now. Nice to meet you.
>> And then let's get her to read this out.
>> Hey, I haven't seen you in ages. Do you
want to grab some coffee later? I've got
so much to tell you. And as you can
hear, it's a lot more expressive and
less robotic than other texttospech
generators. This sounds very natural.
And then here's a quick Japanese
example. So here's the reference voice.
And then let's get this voice to read
this transcript out.
So, those are some quick examples. The
awesome thing is they've released
everything already. So, on this GitHub
repo, it contains all the instructions
on how to download and run this locally
on your computer. The models are super
tiny. So, this smallest one is only.1
billion parameters. So the total size of
this is only 244 megabytes. It's not
even a gigabyte in size. So you can
easily run this on just a CPU or just a
normal computer. Anyways, if you want to
use text to speech, especially for
English and Japanese, this is a really
good and lightweight option for you to
use. If you're interested, I'll link to
this page in the description below.
Also, this week, Nvidia releases a very
useful sequential image model called Duo
Genen. Here they call it a multimodal
model designed to automatically switch
between modalities to generate coherent
interled image and text sequences. So
here's an example of that in action. You
can get it to make a step-by-step
tutorial on how to cook a certain dish
and it would actually plan this out
sequentially. It would give you the text
description plus the corresponding image
all from just one prompt. Or for
example, you can ask it to teach you how
to turn a wooden ladder into a blanket
rack. And again, it would generate this
sequential tutorial with a text
description and a corresponding image.
Or you can also get it to do a tutorial
on how to steam fish or cook fried rice
or a ton of other tutorials. It's
basically using its built-in image model
to generate images sequentially so that
it maintains the same consistency and
tone across all the images in your
sequence. Now, that's its main
capability. But in addition to creating
these step-by-step tutorials, you can
also just use it as a standard image
editor. For example, you can get it to
edit images just like Nano Banana. You
can swap their clothing, change the
background, change their expressions,
etc. I'd say the quality of this isn't
as good as Nano Banana Pro. So, I
wouldn't use this by itself to just edit
images, but its tutorial creation
feature where it generates multiple
images sequentially. I think that is a
really useful feature. And because of
this sequential image generation
feature, you can also use it to generate
sequential images for robots so that it
can kind of predict the next step that
would happen. This is very useful for
like generating training images for
robots on how to manipulate objects.
Now, currently they've only released a
technical paper on this. I'm not sure if
they will open source this or not, but
if you're interested in reading further
or checking out more demos, I'll link to
this main page in the description below.
Also, this week, we have a really useful
audio model called Uni Audio 2.0. This
is what they call a unified audio
language model, and this can do so many
things. First of all, this can just do
regular texttospech. So, for example,
you can select a voice and get it to
read out a certain transcript. Here's an
example of that.
>> He began a confused complaint against
the wizard who had vanished behind the
curtain on the left.
>> Or here's another example.
>> Give not so earnest a mind to these
mummy's child.
>> But that's just easy stuff. In addition
to text to speech, this can also
generate sound effects. So, for example,
you can prompt it to generate a large
crowd cheers and applauds. And here's
what we get.
Now, in addition to sound effects, this
can also do text to music. Now, it's not
great at doing this. The lyrics are just
gibberish, but here are some examples.
First of all, here's an energetic
Punjabi folk song.
>> Or here is an example of an Arabic dance
song.
Again, the quality is not great. You're
not going to use this to actually
generate songs, but it's cool how it has
all these abilities built into just one
unified audio model. Now, of course, you
can also input lyrics and get it to
generate a song with these lyrics. So,
here are some examples. long time ago
in Bethlehem.
So the Holy Bible
says
>> one day long.
>> Another cool feature is you can input a
reference dialogue and edit that into
another style. For example, here's our
reference.
>> I dismiss that.
>> And then let's turn this into whisper
style.
>> I dismiss that.
>> Pretty cool. Next, let's edit this
reference audio and turn it into
shouting style. So, here's the reference
audio.
>> Oh, yes, sir.
>> And here's the result.
>> It's not really shouting, so, you know,
the quality of this model isn't great,
but it's really cool that it has all
these features built in. The awesome
thing is they've released everything
already. So, if you click on this GitHub
repo and you scroll down a bit here, it
contains all the instructions on how to
download and run this locally on your
computer. Anyways, if you're interested
in reading further, I'll link to this
main page in the description below. And
that sums up all the highlights in AI
this week. Let me know in the comments
what you think of all of this. Which
piece of news was your favorite? And
which tool are you most looking forward
to trying out? As always, I will be on
the lookout for the top AI news and
tools to share with you. So, if you
enjoyed this video, remember to like,
share, subscribe, and stay tuned for
more content. Also, there's just so much
happening in the world of AI every week,
I can't possibly cover everything on my
YouTube channel. So, to really stay
uptodate with all that's going on in AI,
be sure to subscribe to my free weekly
newsletter. The link to that will be in
the description below. Thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one.